So let's take a look at this in detail.
So in this random surfing model.
At any page would assume random surfer
would choose the next page to visit, so
this is a small graph here.
That's of course oversimplification of
the complicated web, but let's say
there are four documents here, d1 d2 d3
and d4, and let's assume that a random
surfer or random walker can be on any
of these pages.
And then the random surfer could decide
to just randomly jump into any page.
Or follow a link and then visit the
next page.
So if the random server is at d1.
Then
With some probability that random surfer
will follow the links.
Now there are two out links here.
One is pointing to d3, the other
is pointing to d4, so the random
surfer could pick any of these two to
reach d3 and d4.
But it also assumes that the random
surfer might get bored sometimes, so
the random surfer will decide to ignore
the actual links and simply randomly
jump to any page on the web.
So if it does that, it would be able to
reach any of the other pages, even
though there's no link directly from d1
to that page.
So this is assumed random surfing
model.
Imagine a random surfer is really doing
a surfing like this.
Then we can ask the question how likely
on average the surfer would actually
reach
a particular page like d1 or d2
or d3 really, that's the average
probability of visiting a particular
page.
And this probability is precisely what
Pagerank computes.
So the Pagerank score of the document
is the average probability that
the surfer visits a particular page.
Now, intuitively, this would basically
capture the in link account.
Why?
Because if a page has a lot of in links,
then it would have a higher chance of
being visited because there will be
more opportunities of having the surfer
to follow a link to come to this page.
And this is why.
The random surfing model actually captures the
idea of counting the in links.
Note that it also considers the
indirect in links.
Why? Because if the pages
that point to you have themselves a lot
of in links.
That would mean the random surfer will
very likely reach one of them, and
therefore it increases the chance of
visiting you.
So this is a nice way to capture both
indirect and direct links.
So mathematically, how can we compute
this probability in order to see that
we need to take a look at how this
probability is computed.
So first, let's take a look at the
transition matrix here.
And this is just the metrics with
values indicating how likely I ran.
The random surfer will go from one page
to another, so each row stands for a
starting page.
For example, row one would indicate
the probability of going to any other 4
pages from d1, and here we see
there are only two non zero entries,
each is 1 over 2.
So, this is because if you look at
the graph d1 is pointing to d3
and d4, there is no link from d1
to d1 itself or d2, so we've got zeros for
the first 2 columns and .5 for d3 and
d4.
In general, the element in this matrix
M sub i, j is the probability of going
from
d,i to d,j and obviously for each
row the values should sum to 1 because
the surfer would have to go to
precisely one of these other pages,
right?
So this is the transition matrix.
Now, how can we compute the probability
of a surfer visiting a page?
If you look at the surf model then
basically we can compute the
probability of reaching a page as
follows.
So.
Here on the left hand side you see it's
the probability of visiting page d,j at
time T + 1, so it's the next time
point.
On the right hand side you can see the
equation involves the probability of at
Page d,i at time T.
So you can see the subscript index t
here, and that indicates that the
probability that the surfer was at a
document at time t.
So.
The equation basically captures the two
possibilities of reaching at d,j at
time T + 1.
What are these two possibilities?
One is through random surfing and
one is through following a link as we
just explained.
So the first part captures the
probability that the random surfer
would reach this page by following a
link, and you can see the random surfer
chooses this strategy with probability
1 minus alpha as we assume and so there
is a factor of 1 minus alpha here, but
the main part is really sum over all
the possible pages that the surfer
could have been at time t.
There are N pages, so it's a sum
over all the possible N pages. Inside
the sum is a product of two
probabilities.
One is the probability that the
surfer was at d,i the time t.
That's p sub t of d,i.
The other is the transition probability
from the d,i to d,j.
And so in order to reach this d,j page,
the surfer must first be at d,i at
time t and then also would have
to follow the link to go from the d,i
to d,j.
So the probability is the probability
of being at d,i at time t multiplied
by the probability of going from that
page to the target page.
d,j here.
The second part is a similar sound.
The only difference is that now the
transition probability is a uniform
transition probability of 1 / N and
this part of captures the probability
of reaching this page through random
jumping.
Right, so the form is exactly the same and
is.
This also allows us to see why Pagerank
essentially assume the smoothing
of the transition matrix.
If you think about this 1 / N as coming
from another transition matrix that has
all the elements being 1 / N The
uniform matrix, then you can see very
clearly.
Essentially we can merge the two parts.
And because they are of the same form, we
can imagine there's a different matrix
that's a combination of this M and that
uniform matrix, where every element is
1 / N, and in this sense Pagerank
uses this idea of smoothing and
ensuring that there's no zero entry in
such a transition matrix.
Now of course this is time dependent
calculation of probabilities.
Now we can imagine if we want to
compute the average probabilities, the
average probabilities probably would
satisfy this equation without
considering the time index.
So let's drop the time index and just
assume that they will be equal.
Now this would give us N equations
because for each page we have such
equation and if you look at the what
variables will have in these equations
there are also precisely N variables.
Right?
So this basically means we now have a
system of N equations with N variables.
And these are linear equations.
So basically the problem boils down to
solve this system of equations.
And here I also showed the equations in
the matrix form.
It's the vector p here.
Equals a metrics of the transverse of
the matrix here.
And multiply by the vector again.
Now, if you still remember some
knowledge that you've learned from
linear algebra and then you will
realize this is precisely the equation
for item vector, right when you multiply
the matrix by this vector, you get the
same value as this vector.
And this can be solved by using
iterative algorithm.
So the equations here on above are
basically taken from the previous
slide, so you see the relation between
the.
The Pagerank scores of different pages
and in this iterative approach or power
approach, we simply start with.
Randomly initialized vector p and
then we repeatedly just updated this p
by multiplying the matrix here by this
p vector.
So I also show a concrete example here.
So you can see this now if we assume
alpha is .2, then with the example that
we show here on this slide we have the
original transition matrix here.
Right? That includes the
graph, the actual links, and we have
this smoothing transition matrix
uniform transition matrix representing
random jumping and we can combine them
together with a linear interpolation to
form another matrix.
That would be like this.
So essentially we can imagine now the
web looks like this. Can be captured by
that there are virtual links between
all the pages now.
So the Pagerank algorithm would just
initialize the p vector first and then
just compute the updating of this p
vector by using this matrix
multiplication.
Now if you rewrite this matrix model
multiplication in terms of just,
individual equations, you will see
this.
And this is
Basically the updating formula for this
particular pages Pagerank score so you
can also see you if you want to compute
the value of this updated score for d1
you basically multiply this rule.
Right, by this column.
And we take the dot product of the two.
That would give us the value for this
value.
So this is how we updated the vector.
We started with some initial values for
these guys.
For this and then we just revise
the scores we generate a new set of
scores and the updating formula is this
one.
So we just repeatedly apply this and
here it converges and when the metrics
is like this where there's no zero
values and it can be guaranteed to
converge.
And at that point that we will just
have the Pagerank scores for all the
pages. Now
we typically set the initial values
just to 1 / N.
So Interestingly, this updating formula
can be also interpreted as propagating
scores over the graph.
Can you see why?
If you look at this formula and then
compare that with this graph?
And can you imagine how we might be
able to interpret this as essentially
propagating scores over the graph?
I hope you will see that indeed we can
imagine we have values initialized on
each of these pages, so we can have
values here.
Let's say that's 1 /4 for each, and
then we're going to use this matrix to
update these scores.
And if you look at the equation here.
This one.
Basically, we're going to combine the scores
of the pages that possibly would lead
to reaching this page, so we'll look at
all the pages that are pointing to this
page and then combine their scores and
propagate the score.
The sum of the scores to this document
d1.
So we look at the scores that represent
the probability that the random surfer
will be visiting the other pages before
it reached d1, and then just do
the propagation to simulate the
probability of reaching this page.
d1.
So there are two interpretations.
One is just the matrix multiplication
and repeatedly
multiply the vector by this matrix, but
the other is to just think of it as
propagating the scores repeatedly on
the web.
So in practice the computation of
Pagerank score is actually efficient
because the matrix is sparse and there
are some ways to transform the equation
so that you avoid actually literally
computing the values for all those
elements.
Sometimes you may also normalize the
equation and that would give you a
somewhat different form of the
equation, but then the ranking of pages
will not change.
The results of this potential problem of
zero out link problem.
In that case, if the page does not have
any out link then the probability of
these pages would not sum to one
basically the probability of reaching
the next page from this page will not sum to one.
Mainly because we have lost
some probability mass when we assume
there's some probability that the
surfer will try to follow links,
but then there's no link to follow.
And one possible solution is simply to
use a page specific damping factor
and that could easily fix this.
Basically, that's to say alpha would be
1.0 for a page with no out out link.
In that case the surfer would just have
to randomly jump through another page
instead of trying to follow a link.
So there are many extensions of page
rank.
One extension is to do topic specific
Pagerank. Noted that Pagerank doesn't
really use the query information so.
So we can make Pagerank query
specific, however, so for example in
the topic specific Pagerank we can
simply assume when the surfer is bored
the surfer is not going to randomly
jump to any page on the web.
Instead it's going to jump to only
those pages that are relevant to a
query.
For example, if the queries is about the
sports, then we could assume that when
it's doing random jumping it's going to
randomly jump to a sports page.
By doing this, then we can bias and
Pagerank to
topic like sports and then if you know the
current query is about sports and then
you can use this specialized Pagerank
score to rank documents that would be
better than if you use a generic
Pagerank score.
Pagerank is also a general algorithm
that can be used in many other
applications for network analysis,
particularly for example social
networks.
You can imagine if you compute the
Pagerank scores for social network
where a link might indicate friendship
relation, you'll get some meaningful
scores for people.